the movie opens up in an apocalyptic
world which has been ravaged because of
an unknown reason the once thriving
Humanity has been laid to complete waste
as only a few survivors remain among
them is our protagonist Juliet who is
driving through a desolate City she is
part of a 30-member clan who has somehow
managed to survive the harsh conditions
currently Juliet is on a mission to look
for any edible resources inside her van
we see a gun and a picture of herself
with her ex-lover Jack it appears that
he didn't survive the apocalypse after a
while Juliet enters an abandoned gas
station hoping to find anything useful
she carefully steps inside ready to
shoot whatever lies ahead when Juliet
doesn't find anything though she decides
to take a short rest but just then her
sleep is disturbed by a growling sound
coming from the Upper Floor Juliet is
terrified by the noise so she
immediately rushes to her van and leaves
it is evident that something dangerous
and scary is inhabiting this apocalyptic
Wasteland in the next scene Juliet
communicates with the leader of her clan
Harry he inquires if she found anything
useful to which she replies in the
negative he then asks her to stay out of
danger and get back to their Hideout as
soon as possible Juliet agrees and after
she ends the call she takes a shortcut
since her Van's batteries are running
out on her way she comes across an RV
where she finds a fatally wounded man
with his last breaths he pleads with her
to end his misery however Julia
dismisses his request asserting that she
doesn't want to waste her bullets on him
she then asks if there's any food inside
the RV to which the man says yes but he
also warns her that the creature also
known as the reaper is locked inside
hearing this Juliet contemplates for a
while and eventually decides to go
inside as soon as she enters a few
gunshots are heard and the windows
shatter Juliet has managed to kill the
barbaric Reaper but when she steps
outside the poor man has already died
following this Juliet gathers all of his
supplies loads them into her van and
leaves while on the road she seems to be
in a hurry as it is revealed that the
Reapers only come out at night they're
scared of the daylight spent most of the
day time under shade meanwhile as Juliet
is driving a gust of wind suddenly blows
her picture away this distracts her
momentarily causing her van to Skid off
track and flip over multiple times the
impact knocks Juliet out and with this
the movie goes into a flashback several
years ago before the apocalypse took
place Juliet is seen standing in an art
gallery the owner of the place jack
approaches her and tries to engage in a
conversation however Juliet is
uninterested she reveals that she's here
for the food and also because it's
raining outside Jack doesn't seem to
mind this so he shows her a painting and
asks her to observe it closely Juliet
rudely comments that it is ugly but Jack
tells her to look into its inner beauty
as everything is artificial as the two
continue talking they become more
comfortable with each other after the
exhibition ends Jack suddenly asks
Juliet if she would like to see his
place the latter agrees without much
thought and the two head there upon
arriving Juliet is astonished by his
apartment which appears to be lavish
Jack then offers her some wine and
cheese and the to engage in further
conversation however when Jack starts
asking about her personal life she
becomes suspicious of his motives and
abruptly leaves the following night the
two once again cross paths this time
jack spots her in a bar where she is
with another man surprisingly she hands
him some narcotics revealing that she is
a dealer later a deeply curious Jack
Tails her to her apartment and learns
that her situation is really bad she is
living among other narcotic dealers in
very Grim conditions when Juliet finally
notices Jack she becomes angry and
starts berating him jack attempts to
console her and even proposes to help
her but she refuses at last when Juliet
injects a substance in her veins Jack
realizes that she is an addict too hence
he leaves the place disappointed several
weeks passed by and one day a bruised
Juliet suddenly shows up at his
apartment Jack doesn't even ask what
happened and he begins tending to her
wounds he then cleans her up and leaves
her to rest in his room the next morning
Juliet wakes up feeling better and joins
Jack for breakfast once they are done
Juilliard requests that she be let out
for a while claiming that she needs some
fresh air however Jack knows that she
desperately wants to inject the
substance again he locks all the doors
and as a result Juliet becomes livid she
begins smashing different objects in his
room demanding that he release her
however Jack just lets her release her
anger when she calms down he holds her
tight and eventually kisses her this
serves as the beginning of their tragic
and heartbreaking relationship several
weeks later Jack buys a new house in the
outskirts of the city which he feels is
perfect for Juliet as they move in
together she feels a bit nervous as this
is a big step in her life in response
Jack lovingly touches her face saying he
will always be there for her later he
shows her around the place it explains
that this is where their children will
grow up Juliet like always is skeptical
and she isn't sure if she is ready to be
a mother however Jack tells her that the
most important thing is that they are
together they will surely make it work
his prediction turns out to be true as
just a few few months later Juliet
becomes pregnant she reveals the news to
him making him excited unfortunately
things quickly take a dark turn as the
baby is stillborn due to Juliet's past
drug use this causes a significant
impact on the couple's relationship and
Juliet goes into her relapse being the
perfect man that he is Jack Still puts
up with her and always tries to make her
feel better however one night he finally
snaps Jack is tired of Juliet running
away every day to meet her junky friends
in a fit of rage he breaks up with her
leaves the car and decides to use the
subway instead hours later as Juliet is
having drinks in a bar a News Channel
reports that there was a deadly chemical
attack in the subway which is claimed to
the lives of more than 30 people this
scares Juliet as she realizes that Jack
was in the same subway hence she
immediately rushes to see him in the
next scene Juliet arrives at the
hospital where Jack is admitted in the
Intensive Care Unit his larynx and
trachea were burned because of the
chemical attack leaving him unable to
speak Juliet goes near his room which is
separated by thick layer of plastic and
apologizes for what happened in response
Jack uses a white board and a marker to
express his emotions even in this
critical State he mentions that he loves
her and asks her to never give up this
makes Juliet hopeful of his survival
however the next morning when she enters
his room she learns that Jack passed
away due to his injuries leaving her
utterly devastated the movie then
flashes back to the present where Juliet
finally regains Consciousness she feels
a sharp pain in her leg as a bone
appears to be sticking out to make
matters worse her gun is a few feet away
from her since it is already night time
Juliet fears that she will be eaten
alive by the Reapers hence she decides
to take matters into her own hands after
a lot of effort Juliet somehow manages
to free her leg from under the steering
wheel she then pushes her fractured bone
back in place washes the wound with
alcohol and makes a tourniquet for
herself the pain is excruciating but it
is her only hope of survival after this
Juliet grabs her radio and attempts to
call Harry but the signal is too weak
suddenly she hears footsteps approaching
her way so she quickly grabs her gun and
hides inside the van we are then finally
given a glimpse of this Reaper the legs
appear to be similar to that of a
deformed human being Juliet nervously
watches from under the van hoping the
reaper won't see her but unfortunately
Harry calls her at the same time causing
her radio to beep panicked she throws
away the radio to distract the creature
Juliet is certain that she will be found
but to her good luck the reaper hears
something in the distance and walks away
a few hours passed by and Juliet throws
some glow sticks outside to check if the
reapers are nearby when she spots no one
she slowly moves ahead still unaware of
her surroundings just then Juliet Hears
A Sound and when she turns around she
spots the deadly Reaper on top of her
van terrified she shoots at it once
before returning to her Hideout inside
the van she waits for the creature to
come pointing her gun in that direction
however the reaper appears from behind
and Yanks the window cover taking Juliet
by complete surprise its face to be
completely deformed as if the flesh has
melted away Juliet struggles to break
free and when nothing works she starts
the car and presses down the accelerator
luckily the wheels start moving and this
hurts the monster causing it to retreat
momentarily after the close call Juliet
finally fixes her radio and contacts
Harry she frantically tells him that
she's being attacked by a Reaper in the
middle of nowhere Harry promises to come
for help but for that he will need her
exact location so he asks her to turn on
the beacon located inside the van
Juliette does is told and finally gets
the device to work but when she looks
around she notices that the reaper is
back it launches a deadly attack on her
but in the nick of time Juliet turns on
the headlights causing the reaper to run
away in agony after this she again
receives a call from Harry who mentions
that he has tracked her location but
unfortunately he won't be able to arrive
until the morning as it is too dangerous
right now this leaves Juliet devastated
as she realizes that she is on her own
now a while later she hears a vehicle
pass by so she desperately honks the
horn for help a man hears it and
approaches her van unfortunately he
turns out to be a cannibal he forcibly
enters the van and attempts to stab
Juliet but right then the reaper shows
up it menacingly drags the man out and
kills him as the reaper feasts on the
cannibal Juliet thinks of committing the
unthinkable but just then she remembers
Jack's final words who asked her to
never give up this gives her enough
motivation to keep living so she decides
to fight back in a final Act of
desperation Juliet brings out two fuel
canisters she then lights a flare and
waves it around to attract the reaper
when it eventually shows up she leads it
to the gas containers Juliet then
strategically shoots them causing them
to explode but to her dismay the cunning
Reaper manages to run away without being
harmed after this a fight ensues between
the two the reaper keeps dragging Juliet
around but for some reason doesn't harm
her taking advantage of this she shoots
it twice at point-blank range seemingly
finishing it off but when the Sun
finally Rises the reaper appears to be
alone Juliet tries to shoot at it once
again but she has run out of bullets as
she hardly reloads her gun the reaper
climbs on top of her when it gently
touches her face it finally Dawns on
Juliet that the monster is none other
than the love of her life Jack all this
while he was only trying to get close to
her and be with her despite being a
monster now he still has the same
feelings for Juliet he once had
overwhelmed with emotions Juliet goes
into a flashback and remembers the time
when Jack asked her to observe the
painting he had told her to see the
inner beauty as everything is artificial
in the present Juliet in tears tells
Jack that she loves him a lot then in a
tragic ending she points her gun at both
of them finishing it all subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching